hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembers and welcome to the first
installment of sequel month January I
have to review I had to review terrible
terrible sequels to movies I've already
looked at and if these sequels are
anything like the movie I just saw I'm
in serious shit bad
serious serious shit
neverending story
I mean this is a this gum literally
fresh from the ass Avis gun this is one
of the worst left's in the face to a
really great movie since the last laugh
and a face to it but give neverending
story to some credit it wasn't this this
is the Mortal Kombat 2 of sequels the
Batman and Robin's up well it's still
bad it's one of the worst sequels to a
franchise I have ever seen
period this is the movie these are the
know some things are wrong with the
movie so as you can imagine there's a
lot to talk about
so I will do my best to keep this review
under a millennium long but I make no
promises let's take a look first of all
look at this stellar computer animation
doesn't it look like it's just leaping
out at you well the credits look more
three-dimensional I guess this is
supposed to be Fantasia but lord knows
it looks more like a theme park from the
fucking White Witch of Nardi apparently
there's this double do Shu spends most
of his time recording the tales of the
neverending story
yeah just burn the pages that depart one
palatal save you for hours they move you
gave the writing stylus we spotlights
feeling like this is a side nicety is
not doing the nasty that's the name of
our villain folks the nasty in the first
film in less than nothing the second
film is the emptiness and in this film
it's the nasty the hell's the villain in
the next felt gonna be called though to
stop the last year even temporary
and special young a voracious reader of
great imagination and extraordinary
Japan you got the dick cheese from Free
Willy enjoy he's being chased by some
bullies and hides in the school library
where he comes across the librarian from
the first two films played this time by
Freddy Jones yeah is it me or do they
always meet this way mr. coriander do
you remember me
Bastian Bastian Balthazar bux they
changed actors twice neverending story
that is strictly reference book from now
on and does not be taken from the
library under any circumstances that's
why I left it that did the open for
anybody to steal seriously I said take
better care of my box so he looks in the
book and sees his story is once again
being told through the text apparently
his dad got married to a divorcee named
Jane Baxter
Jane's house more suited for a family of
four which for Bastian in a new room
neighborhood worst of all new school
well thank God the librarian just
happened to move at the exact same time
to the exact same school or maybe when
he you know vanished into thin air from
the last film he just happened to
reappear at the school that's fuckin
lucky he also gets a little sister a
bratty little bitch and a half who wants
nothing to do with Bastian you can have
one if you want I got plenty of them
what for Crystal's are so stupid like a
crystal can really grant a wish or
something when did he say it could spare
me this new-age garbage crystals arts
bush grant wishes only the Orang can do
that
can't tell this to anybody okay the
Orang is a necklace of the childlike
Empress the ruler of all Fantasia the
neverending story
you're crazy
so after hearing his Dungeons & Dragons
wet dream she locks herself in a room
and tries to cope with the situation
yeah thank god she's not into all that
New Age crap she just likes to express
her feelings on acoustic guitar and sing
lyrics that wouldn't make it into a
joule power train park and you left me
Sebastian's dad who looks like a pig
that just ate Vince Vaughn tries to help
his new wife be a good parent
I'll be pulling the car out of the
garage you know when you're ready I'm at
Bing
but Bastian decides he wants to look
cool on his first day of school so he
goes for something along the lines of a
green hair guy from Sin City James Cole
no III don't but don't worry you look
perfectly impressive yeah you can call
it the Idris woke up and saw the box
office results for neverending story
three look oh my god the new brother
well depends do you believe too obvious
thirty-year-olds trying to play high
school students is for real where's man
drew
Nicole I gotta get this stuff on my hair
I can't show you the bathroom reading
okay hold it hold it hold it we got to
go back and do bullet points because
there's just too many things wrong with
this seat first off fast Jack Black what
second why would an entire school
literally run away from a group of
bullies whether they stuff their pants
with TNT or something third that's Jack
Black
what fourth they're literally called the
nasties in the first film that nothing
was an abstract entity in the second
film the emptiness was the human form of
dying imagination in this film it's
literally just a bunch of bullies names
and nasties fucking and inspiring is
that to go from complex ideas destroying
worlds to one half of tenacious be
acting like a dick mule boy they keep
upping the ante don't they now to his
credit Jack Black does seem like the
only actor who's actually having fun
with this performance don't get me wrong
it's still written terribly that's a lot
of fun to see him try and pull something
off with it
hey guys show me where the men's room is
mm-hmm well I think it had only be right
we personally escort you to the men's
room
so they lock him in the storage room
until the janitor comes along it spots
them yo mr. John what's up how many
times are you two easels gonna repeat
the 12th grade
well so that's why I have the high
school students look like they're in
their 20s the next time we catch is just
down here
you'd have us all expel prevention
knocks on the door and tells the janitor
what happened resulting in them getting
expelled which leads us to where the
story left off with bastion finding the
book kind of weird that you read all the
things they already knew happen to
himself but the Holy's find him and
continue to chase him down
hey you know what I don't miss in this
film Fantasia I don't miss it at all the
other films would have gotten there by
now but this bill feels that taking its
time to show us how to eat driving lead
boring our main character is is much
more important hell but maybe the
flippin film is escape from Fantasia
bitch of the cultu trying to get the
fucking Fantasia dick back Fantasia it's
my story and I say return to Fantasia to
skip the nasty
that's your transporting effect you'd be
lucky if you didn't get a seizure
traveling that way I want to go to
Fantasia not so finally he transports
himself back to Fantasia oh hey yeah I
didn't know Martin Short was in this
movie so it comes across the nomes from
the first movie who are now Irish for
some reason as Jack Black continues to
try and find Bastian when I get my hands
on that slippery weasel I'm gonna rock
his world oh yo baby he's hiding you
want to be plus yo Balthazar you know
these guys are making bulk and skull of
like professional assassins did anybody
check in there so they find the book and
here's a big shock or actually able to
read in order to escape the nasties the
nasties Bastian rushed inside the
nearest door the school library
you know how can something that's
happening right now
be in this book very possible he then
slapped himself in a bout of overacting
happiness so the nasties eventually
figure out that the book is alive and
that Bastian is inside maybe we could
make a few things happen to him so the
nasty start to destroy the world by
jumping on chairs yeah honestly they
never explain how they're controlling
the story they never write in the book
they don't read the book out loud it's
just sort of in their control but
luckily some characters are still around
to help we need a ride to Silver City to
see the Empress oh my god what are they
doing about gore not only do the
animatronics look like the butt cheeks
from Chucky Cheese but the character is
totally backwards
Falkor was a dignified creature he was
optimistic and wise this abomination is
a Glenn
idiot he's like the flying version of
Patrick the starfish things will work
out fine a trail never give up
and good luck will find you oh wait
that's just what I heard it could be
just a rumor this is no weather from
mountain flying do I even wanna go go on
an adventure but he's not the only
character who gets an atoll draping from
this film just take a look at what they
did to the rockbiter and family yeah
there's TV and Fantasia now folks TV
isn't it like the number one thing that
keeps children from reading and they
have it in Fantasia a world that can't
survive unless children are reading
fucking hypocritical world it's
someone's day over rocks before lunch
yes people that is the rock fighter
allow me to cry for you what have you
done maybe what have you done you turn
this character into a fucking set cop no
I'm serious it's a fucking sick huh
what's the fucking Flintstones or the
fucking dinosaurs don't fucking believe
me take a fucking look at the fucking
scenes from those fucking shows and then
fucking zombies they can fucking look
like some fucking same thing you fucking
fuck fuck but oh wait there's more
just listen to what the fucking family
sounds like which ones going over to
wandering mountains and breaking off
about a half a ton of limestone
there's no remotely female I mean at all
at all is there any indication that
that's a female voice no no no no no
that thing has a dick it has ballsy
testicles he married a rock best times
but wait there's more take a look at how
the baby sounds
because it's all the same guy yeah it's
the same actor doing all three parts I'm
convinced there is no attempt to
disguise the voice at all they just
didn't care but wait just what you think
they can't possibly take away any more
dignity from this character they can't
fuck fuck him enough
looking for advance
yeah
let me make one thing perfectly clear
this is not jumping the shark I'll
repeat that again this is not jumping
the shark
this is jumping the shark coming back
shooting into the balls raping it eating
his flesh consuming its soul mouthing
its head on the wall and they're doing
the same thing that's one more fucking
sharks just happening site don't believe
me
you don't fucking believe me well let's
take a look at the original film ever
spelled back to back they look like big
good strong hands
don't they
my little friends but nothing hold them
right out of my way we see the childlike
Empress who of course looks nothing like
a child and her sidekick make a mind as
they enter the icy Mountain the same
time Bastian dies Empress how are you
not well we must not give in to the
nasty my law wouldn't fight that dirty
you will take the Orang with you you
shall wish yourself back to the human
world then use the power of the Orang to
return the book to the safe hands of the
keeper wait this is the third time he's
lost that goddamn spark it couldn't be
in worse hands or she don't mailed it to
the Marx Brothers so for some reason
that's never fully explained they all
have to hold hands and wish together in
order to get back to the real world
The Rock biters baby sneaks in though
and this somehow screws everything up
who by wish never running story with
leaves nasties no Bastian stop I can't
believe this fuck now that with you in
the human world
why not
yeah why not but it's his imagination
why can't you just wish there in the new
Fantasia it's my imagination I'll just
make sure they're in the new Fantasia
know best that's it just know there's no
other reason why why can't he just wish
them back now best it seems like he
could do it really easily no best I mean
he's got the little fake now best just
take two seconds
what have you - fuck you it's your damn
world you backed it up however you want
so Falkor is stuck somewhere in the sky
tree pube here is stuck in the forest
the gnomes are trapped in Nome Alaska
get it and that petrified turd is stuck
somewhere on Mount Rushmore
so Bastian is stuck at home literally
waiting for his friends to find him as
his dad comes in to check any problems
for the new school making any friends
I'm fine okay how much you want to bet
they're not gonna bring up at all any of
the knowledge that the father got about
the book from the last movie even though
clearly in the last film he proved that
everything he said about the story was
real so there's nothing you wanna
nope not even the mention continuity is
fucked like a two-dollar whore the only
thing he says are two words that pretty
much sum up the entire movie in a
nutshell sucks okay okay good talk son I
think we've really come a long way after
our break through this really bites
discussion so we see the nasties
literally have a hideout at the mall
behind a garbage dumpster I swear to god
these guys are turning into 1960s Batman
villains every time I turn around you
think maybe we should get our hands on
that clone thing first before we even
get a chance to read about it this book
to go flying right out of our hands
steal the necklace permanent control
over Balthazar a story I'll chase him
round the moons of nippy and round the
antares maelstrom and round perdition's
flames before I give him up we see
Falkor got the baby and are stuck in
some sort of Chinese parade and I have
to admit it's pretty bad when the paper
dragons are looking more realistic than
the actual drag Tarasov choke dragons
hair fuck you but Bastian phones them
and they fly away as nobody questions
why there's a giant white hairy penis
flying in the sky so Falkor flies the
baby and Bastian home and continues to
search for the others babies are much
better
speaking of ripoffs we get those classic
scenes where the kid is hiding the
creature in a comedic way from the
parents but again why doesn't he just
fucking show them the father knows the
world exists our Lacey dan in the last
movie so what's the big deal
oh and here's a real bonehead move
Bastian goes to school the next day
leaving the giant Rock baby and the
all-powerful necklace out in the open
thank God you don't have a bitchy bitch
sister who would steal it for any reason
you just won the dumbass of the Year
award at school we see the nasties
watching it but are waiting for the
right moment to strike
we're supposed to be expelled remember
let's wait till at 3:00 o'clock Bell so
we can take them outside without no one
noticing do you know the Klingon proverb
that tells us revenge is a dish that is
best served but soon the sister figures
out that the Orang has power and here's
a bite she makes fucking wishes with it
thank you God dumbass Bastian never gets
the idea to just wish for shit sure
she's using it to go shopping and dress
up like bozos hooker but hell she's
fucking using it all Bastian has to do
is wish for the neverending story to be
in his hand and all this misery would be
over but no he just sits in his room
praying the problem will fix itself that
technically means that the bitchy sister
is more of a hero that he is because
she's fucking using it hell even the
nasties the villains of this picture are
closer to heroes than Bastian is because
they're actually taking advantage of
what they have why the hell are you in
this movie just leave okay so the
nasties find out that Bastian doesn't
have the necklace and like idiots they
let him go back at home both the gnome
and the tree somehow deliver themselves
to Bastian even though they don't know
his address fuck it I don't care I'll
buy it fill in the potholes yourself
kids cuz this movie ain't gonna do it
for us they're gonna find the sister at
the mall and oh what a coincidence it
happens to be Halloween so they can walk
around without gay
no it's lucky lucky little do they know
though that the nasties are reading
their progress what a dream okay come on
guys Balthasar sisters right upstairs
so the nasties grab the necklace and rot
I don't know they must have used the
Orang to disappear know happen if you
don't get the iron back but you realize
what you've caused huh
I really hope you enjoyed your little
shopping spree it's called doing
something you dumbass look into it
so it looks like the nasties have
control of the necklace and thus all
power in the world
yo Empress Jesus check it out Wilma I'm
the new keeper of the book my name is
not Wilma yeah don't you remember it's
the bus team has failed and the Fantasia
that we know will be a thing of the past
yeah you've really truly learned your
lesson from the last movie he's not very
good at this so the nest he's literally
turned everybody in the world into
arguing jerks because they're nasty
this means the kids parents are at each
other's throats too but luckily they
find the nasties and try to stop them
looks like things are getting a little
nasty over at the Bucs residence you
made that way don't go blaming it on me
I didn't put those words into your
parents mouths they said it themselves
for hates sake I Spit my
but the tree steals it from them and
gives it back to Bastian I wish finally
write down some vengeance on these
assholes big man Balthazar when you got
the necklace put it down what no we're
doing this put it down then we'll see
what a big man you are Bastian place the
necklace down you can't be serious
you're dead to me kid
you're you're just going on all at once
it was if fashion was transformed into a
deadly combination of Bruce Lee Steven
Seagal and jean-claude Van Damme what
Chuck Norris
so yeah the book says he uses all his
karate moves to kick their asses I have
no idea how this is supposed to work is
he writing the story is the sister is
the story just writing itself it's never
explained I have wonderful news though
the movies almost over
the kids go home to their parents the
other Fantasia characters get back safe
they turn the nasties into book worms
and I assume the librarian is gonna burn
that fucking book before it starts any
more shit any Jesus it almost destroyed
the world in this one
oh and we did it we made it through the
neverending story three one of the worst
sequels of all time but on the bright
side the one thing I had to look forward
to through all of this is that I get to
hear that classic neverending story song
again it was in the last two movies it
is my reward for watching this torture I
deserve it
so please play the song alive
have him added fuck
the way
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and you're
watching sequence one down I'd have it
matter fuck
listen that's the winner and the feeling
that I'm on
we must not give in to the nasty